in the last video we had Pete starting
an open-ended mutual fund that was
managed by Pete Inc and mutual funds
normally have nice you know grand names
maybe they call this the Saturn fund and
if there is a Saturn fund out there I
just picked that name at random I'm not
implying that this is you or anything
like that or you know something like the
Galileo funder or saw anything like that
who knows I'm sure there's probably as a
Galileo fund so once again don't sue me
I just made up that name on the fly but
it's managed by Pete incorporated and we
called it an open-ended fund because at
any time one of the people who own a
share or a unit in the fund can redeem
it back from the fund that Pete or the
management company would say okay if you
want if you want at the end of that
video your $180 back we'll buy that will
give you $180 you give back the share
and then we cancel the share and if
anyone wants to add to the fund if they
want to invest the corporation can
create new shares and then issue it to
people and sell it to people and then
that their money will go into the common
pool and the management company would
take fees off of it but that probably
had you asking well if this is an
open-ended fund what is a closed-end
fund or do they even exist and they do
that's what I'm going to talk about here
closed closed and funds and closed-end
funds on some level are a little bit
simpler what happens in a closed-end
fund is that the all of the investors
are essentially or I guess you could say
that the the share structure is locked
in right from the beginning so if Pete
wanted to start a closed-end mutual fund
he would once again register corporation
with the SEC he would market it he would
tell everyone hey I'm Pete I'm an
awesome investor here's my track record
and then he would just get a bunch of
investors so let's say he's able to find
20 investors and that's all he's able to
find so this is 20 right here and I'm
not going to count but let's say there's
20 slices right over he gets 20 people
so let's say they each get $100 though
or they each give $100 so he is able to
raise $2,000 so 20 times 100 so he is
able to raise $2,000 and once that
happens the fund is closed Pete's going
to do his best to manage
this so Pete will manage this and he
will still take a management fee may be
the same 1% but what's fundamentally
different here and he can mark well he
doesn't have to market the fund anymore
because he he can no longer get new
investors and this is actually the main
difference an open-ended mutual fund at
any point in time or I should say at the
end of trading at the end of a day they
can lose investors or they can gain
investor so it's an incentive for an
open-ended fund to constantly market
itself because the manager wants to
manage more money so that he gets more
of a management fee and a closed-end
fund
they'll market it right when they're
creating the fund but once they created
so let's say over here he just got his
20 investors then it is closed he can't
get any more he can't create any more
shares or cancel any more shares but
what can happen so you might say well oh
and the closing fund how do these people
let's say that you're holding one of
these shares let's say you're holding
one share right over here what happens
if you want to if you need a buy a house
or I don't know you owe money to
somebody so you you want to get the
value of your share back and the answer
with a closed-end fund is that you would
then go sell your share to someone else
so this right here you can trade it you
can trade it and you trade it just like
you would trade the stock of any company
in fact when you go and buy or sell a
share of IBM most of the time you're
just buying or selling it from someone
else you're not transacting with IBM the
company you trade it in the secondary
market you're not dealing with the
actual corporation and so that's where
the investor gets their liquidity and
when we say liquidity it allows them to
convert it into cash - because they can
trade it so the big difference
open-ended fund when an investor wants
their money back they have to kind of
commute they have to deal with the fund
itself the fund will buy back their
share if someone wants to invest in a
fund the fund will sell them the share
so they're always dealing with the fund
itself and a closed-end fund once the
fund is created its share pool is fixed
and if someone wants to buy or sell a
share it happens in the secondary
markets they're buying and selling from
each other they're not dealing with the
actual fund manager the disadvantage
from the fund manager here is it's much
less flexible in terms of
going or shrinking the fund the
advantage is this fund manager doesn't
have to keep cash around in case in case
the shareholders want to redeem in the
open-ended fund we saw that the manager
has to keep some cash around in case one
of the investors wants their money back
here the closed-end fund he knows that
no one can get their money back right
here so he can just did it he or she can
invest as they see fit